justice fairness the rule of law
those should be bedrocks of our country
we're a nation of laws and the law has
the potential to be the most
equalizing and unifying force in our
culture our country is unique and that
we describe ourselves as a nation of
laws and not men and women
and we strive to not just be a nation of
laws but a nation of good laws
fair laws just laws that requires
excellence from the women and men we
empower to enforce those laws
we need a justice system that is not
only respected
but worthy of our respect there are 35
000 fbi employees in our country
35 000 just as a point of reference
that's about the same number of people
and the town i grew up in and of those
35 000 total employees
13 000 are fbi agents i work with a lot
of fbi agents when i was a federal and
state prosecutor
and every one of those agents i work
with you would be proud to have as your
next door neighbor
or the coach of your kids team that was
the fbi i knew
but that was not the fbi in charge i
never met or worked with an fbi agent
like peter strzok
when i was a prosecutor i never met an
fbi agent or employee who would let his
own
political opinions influence his work
i never worked with an fbi lawyer or
agent like kevin kleinsmith
kevin kleinsmith was actively vocally
biased against president trump
he also falsified a document to make it
easier to target a political opponent
kevin kleinschmidt thought he was part
of some great moral resistance
a resistance i might add to a duly
elected president
in other words not only did he think he
knew more than you and i
he thought he should break the rules to
target political opponents
he thought it was okay to use these
incredible powers to target
political enemies you know when you
think about law enforcement
and what they're supposed to do is not
just the badge and the gun and the
uniform
it's more than that it's a trust it's a
sacred trust
we trust you with the power to arrest to
detain
to search to impact reputations to
deprive our fellow citizens of their
freedom
those are awesome powers those powers
come from us
they are on loan from us and all we ask
in return is that you use those powers
justly
fairly and appropriately that's not too
much to ask is it
be fair be just be honest don't be
biased
that is not too much to expect
i cannot think of anything more unjust
than manufacturing
evidence to hurt a political opponent
and then lying about it
kevin klein smith was caught he almost
got away with it but he was caught
not by the democrats complaining about
police misconduct
not by the media complaining about our
criminal justice system
kevin kleinsmith was caught by inspector
general michael horowitz
but he was caught and he was prosecuted
and he pleaded guilty
and last week he was sentenced and if
you're wondering what the proper
punishment is for someone
we entrust with these special powers who
manufactures evidence to hurt a
political opponent
if you're wondering you need not wonder
anymore
the proper punishment apparently is
probation
probation not a single day in prison for
abusing your position of trust
to manufacture evidence against a
political opponent
not a single day in prison i do not
pretend to know what the proper senate
should have been for that
i do know this the media and the
democrats wanted roger stone to go to
jail for seven to nine years for lying
to congress
the media and the democrats were
delighted that george papadopoulos and
michael flynn and others were facing
active prison sentences
for making false statements but you
don't hear much about kevin klein smith
who didn't get a single solitary day in
prison
i wish we lived in a world where people
who committed similar offenses received
similar sentences
that would be nice that would be fair
that would be just that would be equal
for five years this country was put
through the insidious allegation that
donald trump
colluded with russia and at the end of
the russia investigation
more fbi employees were convicted of
felonies
than members of the trump family now to
put
all of this in perspective from the
great state of south carolina former
chairman of the
senate judiciary committee lindsey
graham what are your thoughts senator
first of all welcome and what are your
thoughts
on what kevin kline smith did and the
senates he received
well i was shocked really it makes me
wonder about two things
the government recommended from zero to
six months
the foundation of the rule of law as you
said tree is trust by the public
you're presumed innocent but there has
to be some trust
that if somebody's charged with a crime
excuse me there at least something there
if the government is surveilling a
private citizen you have to believe that
the system has some checks and balance
in it
so here we have a case where you have
the fbi's
lawyer whose job it is to screen warrant
applications
manufactures evidence changes evidence
that was exculpatory
to make carter page look bad and he
don't get a day in jail how do you tell
the average american
the system worked where the lawyer in
charge of processing the warrant
pleads guilty of falsifying information
to get not
if he's not available with the
government and he does
and he did what he did and he gets no
time in jail that's a horrible signal to
send to the public
and to deter future misconduct
you know you put your finger on
something senator not only did this fbi
lawyer not get any jail time but some of
bob mueller's prosecutors actually asked
for
leniency and one in particular andrew
wiseman said he didn't even commit a
crime so
for folks looking for equal treatment
for both sides
they shouldn't look at this case
well you're getting rewarded basically
what deterrence comes from this
how would you feel if it was somebody in
your family
where the lawyer at the fbi manufactured
evidence against your loved one
so the government could continue to
surveil them um
accusing them basically of being a
foreign spy and there's no there there
so this sentence is disconnected from
the level
of of the crime it's not going to
restore trust
it's going to create more cynicism and i
just
makes me wonder that he must be helping
the government
because if he's not helping the
government this really is a travesty of
justice
i want to pick on your legal mind for
something else you and i both knew the
lawyers that were
handling defense
good good lawyers uh but they're no
longer
on the team it seems sort of late in the
process be switching legal teams so what
are your thoughts on that what if
anything do you know about
why butch and the others left
well you know they're a great team you
know butch i know butch we know the
whole team
debbie the whole crowd they're really
good lawyers uh too many cooks in the
kitchen i think a lot of
problems there with just never got off
to a good start
i think the people coming in now are
really good lawyers
i think the case is still the same the
bottom line is
i believe an impeachment of president
out of office is unconstitutional
i don't believe the speech given by the
president fits the incitement statute
that it's not a crime and there's
mounting evidence that the people
came to washington pre-planned the
attack before the president ever spoke
so i'm confident of the outcome here
that we're going to have
more than 45 votes for a motion to
dismiss
on the idea that this is
unconstitutional impeachment
pursuing somebody out of office i think
the
the acquittal number will be pretty
close it'll be in the high
40s but the question is true how does
this uh trial in
if the house managers want to use this
as a
political commercial against donald
trump and republicans
and they want to call witnesses now they
didn't call
during the impeachment process in the
house this thing could go for
weeks or months and that would be bad
for the country so
to my democratic colleagues if you vote
to call one witness
none were called in the house get ready
for a long trial
well we've only got a couple of seconds
but let me ask you do you anticipate
witnesses being called and then
being cross-examined
i hope not they didn't call in in the
house i think we know what happened that
day
but if you open up that can of worms
we'll want the fbi to come in
and tell us about how people actually
pre-planned these attacks
and what happened with the security
footprint at the capitol
you open up pandora's box if you call
one witness i hope we don't call
any and we vote and get this trial over
next week when it starts
well i know you're on the jury and i've
often wondered whether or not you would
ever be picked for jury service
uh and i guess you are next week it
starts
the people of south carolina pick me
i'll try to do right by
amen i'll see you thank you for joining
us senator the left's cracked